okay I think we'll get started so
lecture three I think I have maybe title
is not quite what was announced on the
program but the idea is very much the
same so very quick review of a couple of
points that we've done in the first two
lectures we saw how to use same model
comparison games and locality results to
establish limits on the expressive power
of first-order logic and to some extent
also monadic second our logic for
instance we show that you could use the
locality of first-order logic logic to
show that connectivity is not doable in
monadic existential second-order logic
melanic second-order logic we showed the
connection between MSO and automata
yielding two significant results which
you know I kind of give it glimpse the
view here we've got Trachtenberg theorem
which relates MSL to regular languages
of strings and course else theorem which
basically gives a limit on the
expressive power of Emma so you can
think of it that way or in other ways it
provides it an efficient algorithm for
evaluating MSO formulas on structures
which effectively are decomposable right
so the the important property of Emma so
here is certain kinds of decompositions
of structures we're evaluating the MSO
formula on the structure can be reduced
recursively to evaluating it on its
component parts and tree decompositions
provide the natural way of doing that
and that's that's the core of course
else theorem so in today's lecture I
want to return to first-order logic I
talked about the complexity of deciding
this is what foki on called the query
evaluation problem we have a finite
structure a and we have a formula Phi
and we want to decide whether Phi is
true in a and as for Kuhn argued that
this can be done essentially
in time well given this thing has two
parameters as input structure and
formula this is exponential time in
polynomial space but breaking it down
into its parameters you can roughly say
it is if n is the size of the structure
the length of the formula times the size
of the structure raised to the power of
the nesting depth of the quantifiers in
fact if you do it carefully you can make
this the number of variables that appear
rather than the nesting depth but this
is good enough for our purposes and the
space required is M times log n the
number of quantifiers times log of
besides the structure essentially you
have one if you will pointer into the
structure for every variable that
appears and the pointer requires login
bits to point to an element of the
structure so the problem so this problem
is in polynomial space this as I said is
a query evaluation problem I call it the
satisfaction problem in the sense that
this is the satisfaction relation and so
we're talking about the complexity of
this binary relation right on on finite
objects often in the literature you this
will also this also goes under the name
of the model checking problem for
first-order logic so all of these mean
the same thing so the problem is in P
space but if you fix the formula file to
get what for Keyon called the data
complexity for a fixed formula file the
collection of structures that satisfy it
is decidable in logarithmic space in
polynomial time right that's just what
this says if L and M are constants
that's a polynomial and that's
logarithmic function
so but the problem has given with a as a
binary relation on two objects is in
fact pspace-complete
well even for fixed a so you can fix a
and okay you know it'll be a two element
structure even and the collection of
formulas five that are true in it is a
piece is pspace complete in general
because you called qvf as a special case
the title of this slide is first order
contained in the initial segment of P
there's a title of a paper by Stahl boys
can't Iceland that appeared well as easy
about 2000 years ago and the question
they posed disk is it possible that
there is a fixed C so that for any first
order formula the models of the formula
are decidable in time n to the C and
this is what they mean by an initial
segment of polynomial time could it be
the case and the answer is well
if P equals please place the answer is
yes right for the simple reason that
then the satisfaction relation itself
being in peace base is in polynomial
time and so in particular for any fixed
formula the class of structures that
satisfy it is definable in this time
bound n to the C for for a fixed value
of C so though we suspect the answer is
no it's going to be hard to prove
because to prove its no you have to
separate P for P space okay
now this is the question as they they
pulls it a more uniform version of the
question is can you find a constant C
and some computable function so that
it's not absolute the satisfaction
relation is in this sort of time okay so
rather than saying for each fixed
formula is there an end to the C
algorithm we won't really want is
something that will translate formulas
into n to the C algorithms right
computable and that would mean that the
evaluation problem the pre evaluation
problem the satisfaction problem isn't
that sort of complexity okay so this is
the more reasonable form of the question
again of course we expect the answer to
this in general is no and I mean we can
make the no answer a bit more solid than
this thing over here in the framework of
parametrized complexity so this kind of
complexity is what's called a problem
with this hair complexity said we fixed
parameter tractable right really it's
saying that for any fixed value so this
is complexity expressed in terms of two
parameters L N and C is a constant and
it's saying if you fix the parameter L
this is tractable but in a sort of
effective computable sense rather than
in this sense okay so this is what we
call the class FPT problem solvable in
this way now i assume not everybody here
knows about the framework of
parameterize complexity there's a whole
slew of complexity classes i mean the
idea is you know classically we define
complexity classes like P and NP and so
on all by measuring complexity in terms
of one parameter the size of the input
parameters complexity is well what about
if we consider the input to be
multi-dimensional it has several
parameters you want to express the
complexity in terms of several
parameters but we want something akin to
the lower bounds methods we have of
complexity theory of np-completeness and
set cetera so we have we have to define
complexity classes somewhat differently
and in this context FPT is considered
the sort of the tractable case so
if you have an input which is expressed
in terms of two parameters we don't
really care about the dependence of the
parameter L as long as for fixed values
of hell
it's tractable and tractable here means
polynomial time and the exponent itself
doesn't depend on the upon L okay that's
the that's the important thing
so that's what we call F PT and then
there's a hierarchy of in what are
considered intractable complexity class
I'm not going to run through the
definitions of these okay and they're
sort of complete problems at each level
of the hierarchy there's this thing that
sits on top called aw star and it turns
out that you can show that a
satisfaction relation for first-order
logic is in aw star complete so it's
very unlikely that is going to be an FPT
okay so this kind of puts this in a
solid basis but what I want to do in
this talk is talk about restricting the
Towser structures particularly so
notions of sparsity of and finding
classes or structures where this
evaluation problem the satisfaction
relation turns out to be FPD so in some
sense okay this is a good point to
illustrate this so we're looking at the
satisfaction relation for first-order
logic now people who define the these
parameterize complexity classes were
often interested in graph problems so
let's look at a little bit of the define
ability of graph problems a classic
example is the vertex cover problem here
it is for fixed value of K I can write
down a first order formula that says
there is a vertex cover in the graph of
size K right so I've used this example
before the exist K elements and then for
every pair of elements which form an
edge one of the end points is in this
set X 1 to XK that says there's a vertex
cover now the vertex cover is the
classical example of a problem which is
FPT in the sense that there is an
algorithm that solves it which is
exponential in K
and times a linear function of n okay
it's an np-complete problem but it can
be solved tractable what with a function
which is X the exponential in K the
dependence on n is linear
and notice so here I'm writing down a
formula which depends on K so I'm
translating the vertex cover problem
into first-order logic and the
translation takes the value K to a
formula whose length is dependent on K I
can do the same for say independent set
I could have written clique but there's
a reason why I'm saying independent set
the independent set problem for a fixed
value of K says there exists K elements
since the pairwise is no edge between
them right there is an independent of
that K the size K sorry
you're right yes yeah and X is different
from XA right so the independent set
problem is w1 complete so this already
shows that the satisfaction relation for
first-order logic is w1 hard right
because this is a reduction which takes
an independent set and for each value of
K writes down the formula whose length
depends on K which is true in the graph
if and only if there's an independent
set dominating set is w2 complete turns
out and I can here's the first order
formula which says there's a dominating
set of size K says there exist K
elements and for every Y if Y is not
among the X K then there's an edge from
one of the x x i's to Y okay
yes under FPT reductions which is more
relaxed notion right
okay so and then I mean it's not hard to
construct formulas which give you
complete problems at every level of the
W hierarchy and as I said the
satisfaction problem turns out to be
complete for this class a W star which
sits right at the top okay so now that
we all want to say is if we were can you
restrict the class of structures one way
to get a handle of this is restricted
class of structures and say we're given
a first order formula and a structure
from it from this class serious yes
there I mean the the this is this is
quite right I mean well you can take it
I mean it is you can you you you you can
take it as formulas with you know K
existential quantifiers and then close
it under FPT reductions and that's the
class w1 pretty much exactly I mean the
classic definition is just the closure
of click under an under FB T reductions
or a closure of independent set and then
if you look in the floom floom and
growers book on on parameterized
complexity they give the definition very
much in terms of a certain class of
formulas you can write down and then you
close that under FPT reductions okay the
formula you write down is not very
edifying in terms of its setting within
this that's right that's right yeah I
mean I mean the night wave right in the
formula suggests this should be W to
write the the but it turns out to be F
PT okay
I mean I would be interesting I've never
really thought about whether there's a
syntactic explanation of why look at all
you can read off the formula for vertex
cover why it's FPT but I mean the
flumino attempt some sort of thing but
it's it's so now I'm going to look at
this question restrict the class of
structures in a way to make for some
interesting classes this problem becomes
FPT okay and in some sense we've already
seen this because Co sells theorem tells
us that even for melodic second-order
logic rather than first-order logic the
evaluation problem right is as I said
for every fixed formula there's a linear
time algorithm on the class of graphs of
bounded of trivet at most K and since
all the translations of the formula to
the automaton etc are computable it
actually tells you that the satisfaction
relation with the evaluation problem
restrict when you restrict this to be
the class of graphs of three routes at
most K and this problem is FPT even for
the wider class of formulas taking a
micelle okay and now in the rest of the
lecture I'm going to look at some other
classes for which this is not true for
MSO but it turns out you can do it for
first-order logic and essentially the
methods rely on the locality first-order
logic right the methods of proof so
there's going to be applications of
locality in various ways and the first
one I'm going to look at is the class of
graphs of bounded degree so I rewrite DK
for those structures in which every
element has at most K neighbors in the
guy's phone graph of a right remember
the guys McGrath is just the thing which
tells you two things are adjacent if
they appear together in some relation in
the structure
so and this was proved by say so
somewhere in what 1990s in the 90s
anyway that every for every sentence of
first-order logic and every K there's a
linear time algorithm deciding this and
I mean I've the way I've formulated here
is non-uniform right it doesn't tell you
that it there that there is a single
algorithm and because the the proof I'm
going to I mean you can make it all
effective in uniform and prove its SPT
but I'm going to give you a sort of high
level proof which doesn't make that
explicit no this is not true for MSO
unless P equals NP in the sense that I
think what 3 colorability is already
np-complete for graphs of degree bounded
by five maybe even form but certainly
five right graphs of degree 5 s 3
colorability is np-complete I can write
down an MS or sentence which says that a
graph is 3 colorable if this was doable
in linear time then P equals NP 3 okay
so so we don't expect this to be true
for ms all right so crucially this is
specifically about first-order logic now
and the proof as i said is based on
locality first-order logic says this
proof and every k there's a linear time
algorithm which determines so okay i
mean effectively if you want the strong
version then it is a Phi so this is
really saying that the data complains
the complexity is linear I stated but
you can say it more general the more
uniform version is that this can be
decided
in time I really should say order of
some function of K and the length of Phi
times the size of a right so it's linear
na with some computable function of K
and the size of Phi but so so if you fix
K and Phi this is linear that's what
that that's what that form says let's
see the proof and uh I mean the proof
I'll show you give you a horrendous
function okay and
so the proof is based on locality and
says in particularly used hands theorem
and I'm going to give you that proof
there's in some sense a an alternative
based on guys man's locality which
possibly gives you better bounds and but
just I mean I'm going to classes I'm
going to look after this we have to rely
on craftmens theorem but as a sort of
warm-up I'll give you this one so what's
the argument so I'm gonna have to use
the version of hounds theorem that some
kind of alluded to when I gave the the
the we question the one with thresholds
okay so remember in a structure a we
have the neighborhood using a different
notation for neighborhood I suddenly
realized anyway my latex roads were
different in this in this file anyway so
the neighborhood our neighborhood around
an element a in the structure right we
is the substructure of a generated by
those elements at distance at most are
and we before I define the motion of
hands equivalence up to radius R by
saying there's a bijection between the
structures preserving I small for some
types of neighborhoods which basically
means for every isomorphism type the
numbers are the same on both sides now I
want to weaken that requirement saying I
count the numbers only up to a certain
threshold so you count the number of
isomorphism types of each neighborhood
they're the same on both sides or they
are bigger than this threshold Q okay so
as an example right my example of
application right if you remember
recycle and the two cycles or Hanff
equivalent with radius R if radius R is
sufficiently small compared to the
length of the cycle the neighbourhoods
look the same and the sum of these two
silence is the same as this to get the
by ejection now that I put this
threshold Q if the size is big enough
with respect to Q we don't care that the
sizes of the two these two add up to the
same right because all neighborhoods
look the same actually every
neighborhood is a simple path and if
there enough of them they're more than
the threshold Q so these two are our Q
equivalent right okay
and the sort of the stronger version of
hands theorem is that this is already
enough to get us P equivalence with
respect to first order logic up to
quantify rank P right so for every P we
can find our NQ for which this this is
true to structures which are RQ
equivalent or P equivalent yes what is Q
which is something like it should be
said well yeah but but but the the it
should be something like yes I'm trying
I mean I'm trying to picture the game
argument it gets a bit tricky if
I mean the proof I usually think of for
this goes by a guy's Minh serum and that
doesn't give you a direct bound in terms
of P so I mean I'll you know pass on
that for the moment I mean they could
prove this directly as a consequence of
of geitman serum which I mentioned
earlier okay now I'm going to just say
how we use this for the result I want
about bounded degree graphs so suppose
or bounded degree structures suppose a
is in DK has at most K degrees then this
gives us this bound on the size of
neighborhoods the are neighborhood
around a has at most K to the R plus 1
elements right a has at most K neighbors
each of those has at most further at
most K neighbors and so on I mean you
can do better than this is you know you
can do K times K minus 1 to the R but
anyway you go on up to radius R you get
at most K to the R elements and put in
the plus 1 I guess for the element a
itself and therefore there are up to
isomorphism only finitely many such
neighborhoods right there's a bounded
size there are finitely many isomorphism
classes we count these isomorphism
classes only up to a certain threshold
and therefore they're only finitely many
equivalence classes with respect to this
right note if I didn't put that
threshold this well this isn't true
because if I'm counting mmm a number of
neighborhoods unbounded Li obviously I
get many infinitely many classes and you
can characterize each of these class by
a finite table basically lists lists all
these isomorphism types and for each one
of them say the exact number that should
be Q or you know say it's bigger than Q
if it is okay that's a finite table
describing this equivalence class
completely
so now let's say to evaluate the
first-order sentence you start with the
first-order sentence first of all you
just compute the set of tables
describing all these classes and for
each one you say whether Phi is true in
that class or not right and this is what
I mean though it's just the fact that
you can compute this requires proof it
doesn't follow directly from you know
the proof of hamster I mean it requires
work to show that this is computable
from Phi and that's where this function
is coming from right this computation is
independent of any structure you
construct this table beforehand and now
your linear time algorithm once I mean
so from K and file you compute this and
now a linear time algorithm is given the
structure look at each element of the
structure look at its our neighborhood
and determine its type what you know
what isomorphism pipe it is you
construct the table describing dark you
I've forgot these class of a and then
check compare against the table to see
whether the whether it satisfies the
formula Phi okay so it's kind of this is
kind of brute force you know we've just
enumerated all everything that can
happen with every collection of
neighborhoods beforehand and then the
linear time algorithm just looks at all
the neighborhoods there are n of them
and n checks
sorry well it's okay that's okay about
how that's right that's right that's
right yes yes yes yes that's right
which would still be FPT but you're
right to get it linear you have to as
you assume some kind of adjacency list
representation of the structure rather
than so the FPT would follow from that
the statement of the theorem I gave
didn't say FPT it said for every fixed K
and Phi there is a linear time algorithm
and that's a principal things also W
exponential function M oh this is it's
worse than that yeah no it is I mean
it's uh I compute the that's right I
know it this is this function f is still
elementary in this case in the boundary
degree case but it is it's something
like I think for four or five fold
exponential but okay
ok so now I'm going to we looked at
bounded tree widths but there are two
the dependence I mean I mentioned MSL
but even restricted to first order logic
I mean so you have something like this
this function there is non elementary in
the in the case of boundary tree with
right so if you take K to be three words
rather than degree you also have
something like this but then the
function is non elementary in the length
of i it is a lower bound i mean in the
sense assuming F PT is different from w1
or something like that
yes so the next step I mean there's a
sequence of results about extending the
class of structures on which we can
prove something like this the next step
it was essentially by freaking draw it
looking for a common generalization of
bounded degree and bounded tree with
classes okay for both of those we know
this is f PT and they proposed this
thing of bounded local tree width so
what is local tree with
so pick T to be any non decreasing
function on the numbers and we define
the class of graphs or class of
structures of tree with T to be those
structures where for every element if
you look at the are neighborhood around
a wrote the guys men graph but I don't
really well yes no I do mean the guys
men graph of this are neighborhood of a
that has tree with that most TFR so in
other words the neighborhoods we now say
have boundary width the actual tree
which may be a function of the radius of
the neighborhood okay but there is a
function which bounds the tree width of
the neighborhood as a function of the
radius that's what they got bounded
local tree width okay so we say that
class has bounded local tree with if
there is some function T which bounds
this right it bounds the tree width of
every neighborhood so clearly if a class
is bounded tree width it has bounded
local tree roots by bounded by a
constant function right we just take TR
to be the constant function k TK is a
class of graphs abandon of tree width at
most K possible graphs of bounded degree
has bound a tree would simply because
the size of the neighborhood is bounded
and therefore the tree with is bounded
right so you can take TR to be K to the
R plus 1 an example which isn't either
of these but which shows in some sense
why this is an interesting definition is
the collection of planar graphs turns
out has bounded local tree width okay
this is a this is essentially doodle
Epstein and which kind of motivated this
definition in the first place that if
you look at a planar graph of radius R
then it's tree visitor is at most three
times are right you can construct a tree
decomposition it's a rather clever
construction okay
and then freakin growers showed that if
you have a class about a local tree
width and any formula then again
evaluation is FPT in this case they get
a quadratic time algorithm for every
fixed formula right and every fixed yeah
once you fix the class and I want to
tell you I want to describe this result
because there's a very neat application
of of catchments locality which we
haven't seen so far ok so first of all
the idea is the following so you have a
structure a
now around at the air element you look
at the neighborhood of radius R the
value of R is going to come from this
formula you're trying to evaluate the
formula is every formula is local in
some sense you extract from it the
radius of neighborhoods you're
interested in you look at the
neighborhoods of radius R now because
this neighborhood has tree width bounded
by TR and we know that once you bound
the tree width you can evaluate for sir
formulas you can determine the type of
this neighborhood again the value of P
is going to come from the formula right
it doesn't depend on the structure now
this is the difference Hanz theorem
relies on I some more for some types of
these and they're infinitely many of
those guys means theorem is based on the
first-order types of these neighborhoods
and those we can bound the number of
types is bounded and so that's why that
we need to use guidance here so quick
recall guidance theorem tells us that
every first-order sentence is equivalent
to a boolean combination of basic local
sentences and a basic local sentence is
simply the assertion that there are s
elements pairwise far apart from each
other so there are neighborhoods are
disjoint and in each our neighborhood
some formula of C is true okay so it's a
boolean combination of these so again
it's not stated in the theorem but
implicit in the proof from the formula
you can construct this boolean
combination effectively again this is a
highly complex operation blows up the
size of the formula enormously but you
can't construct this so in other words
to show that for fixed formula there is
a quadratic time algorithm it's enough
to show that for any basic local formula
there's a quadratic time algorithm
because you start with the formula you
construct the boolean combination and
then for each one of them you have to do
it okay so how do we evaluate a basic
local formula basically ends in a
structure right we want to say there are
s elements and this holds
as I said for each element you look at
the neighborhood and you determine
whether this formula up site holds in
that neighborhood using the fact that
this neighborhood has bounded tree
widths and therefore we have a linear
time algorithm that does this right
let's say if this thing is satisfied we
called the vertex read and now the point
is we want to determine whether there
exists a set of red vertices of sizes
which are far apart from each other
right say are scattered but anyway the
distance pairwise distance to are from
each other there are neighborhoods are
disjoint this looks kind of difficult
because this looks again like the
independent set problem which is you
know w1 hard so how do we do this we
have a set of vertices that are random
we choose them one by one and every time
we choose a vertex we remove from the
structure its entire neighborhood of
radius 2 R okay not Arbor two are here
so pick one remove all of the all of its
neighbors up to distance to our find
another red vertex remove all of its
neighborhood neighbors upto distance to
our etc okay if this process continues
for s steps we're done we found s
vertices which are pairwise far apart
and their neighborhood satisfies it what
if it stops
well if it stops that means that all for
some you less than s we found u vertices
and every red vertex is within distance
at most two are from these right because
we've run out of red vertices so you
take the two our neighborhood of these
new points take the Union now you have a
substructure of boundary width and
within this you know you have all your
red vertices and finding them is again
evaluating a first order formula on a
structure of boundary width so you're
done
okay
um
okay
well maybe this route
so this story of first-order evaluation
on sparse graph classes kind of
continues we had bounded degree bounded
degree classes and I'm not giving you
all the the whole story we had bounded
tree with
and a common generalization which is
bounded local tree with
okay the next result in the story I'm
not really gonna give you the proof but
I'll introduce mainly to introduce the
terminology have to do with graph
classes defined it defined by excluded
minors so again I'm not going to assume
you know much about graph miner theory
but graph G is said to be a miner for
graph H if you can get G from H by
repeated application of the operations
of deleting an edge deleting a vertex
and all incident edges and contracting
an edge we're contracting an edge is
basically this thing over here I'm not
going to define it more formally right
but if you have two vertices with an
edge between them you replace them by a
single vertex whose neighborhood is all
the neighbors over here okay so if you
can get starting with H through sequence
of these operations you get to G did we
say G is a minor of H more formal
definition is that the graph G is a
minor of H if you can find a sub graph
of H called H prime right subset of the
vertices subset of the edges and a map
which takes let's say the vertices of H
prime to the vertices of G right so that
for every vertex of G its inverse image
is a connected subgraph of H Prime and
for every edge of G there is a edge
between something that map's to you and
something that maps to be
please
pretty much is under this map M of the
vertices of G are called the branch sets
okay I'll come back to the I think this
picture sort of illustrates the idea
it's saying that if a graph of G for
example the triangle is a minor of H
that's really saying we can find three
connected graphs in H with edges between
them which is of course just the same as
saying that H contains a cycle so that's
the one picture illustration of graph -
well the theory of graph - is very rich
and I feel a bit embarrassed standing
here saying it in in front of
distinguished graph theorists but here
are a few facts I mean possibly the most
famous fact about graph miners is that
planar graphs are characterized by
exactly two excluded minors right graph
is planar if and only if it contains
neither the 5-click nor the by clickin
two sets of three elements as a minor
obviously the sub graph of H is a minor
of H it's a transitive relation it
respects tree widths so if G is a minor
of H then the tree root of G is bounded
by the tree root of H so in and in
particular if the tree width of G is
less than K minus 1 then it cannot
contain the K clique is a minor so we
see that the graph of class of graphs
excludes H as a minor if H is not a
minor of any graph in G alright so this
is the definition of excluded minor
classes right si has excluded minors if
there is some graph H use it which is
excluded as a minor right which of
course is the same as saying there's a
sum click it excludes as a minor so we
can actually attach a natural number
parameter to any excluded minor class
the size of the smallest click it
excludes okay so for example TK is an
excluded minor class it excludes the
class of graphs of three with at most K
excludes
the k plus 2 click as a minor
possibly the most famous result in this
whole field is the Robertsons similar
theorem which says that the minor
relation is well cause the order so
basically in any infinite collection of
graphs there exists a pair of grounds
since the one is a minor of the other
okay so there are no infinite int chains
in the graph minor relation an immediate
corollary is that if you have a class
collection of class closed undertaking
minors then there is a finite collection
of excluded minors which characterizes
that class okay that's because obviously
the correction of minor minimal graphs
that are not in the class forms an anti
chain and this tells us that on t chain
must be finite also in the course of
proving this there's an algorithmic
result which says that for fixed I
really should say or fixed graph no I
know this is correct
for fixed G we can find an polynomial
time algorithm which tests whether G is
a minor of H right runs for polynomial
time in size weight sorry
yes though here it's not at all clear
that this function is computable the
dependence on G's
but cases you know that if the class
could be all graphs yes and then this is
the empty set
that's right I think okay so it follows
that any class 'close undertaking minors
is polynomial time decidable because
there is a finite collection of excluded
minors that characterizes it and so we
have a finite table and using this you
can test membership in the class by just
testing for each one of those finitely
many graphs whether it's a minor okay
so let's write MK for the class of
graphs which excludes the K clique as a
minor and the result of flow and draw is
that first-order logic is fixed
parameter tractable on this I'm not
going to tell you how it's done
essentially well maybe I will say
yourself few words essentially this is a
uses the graph structure theory of
Robertson and Seymour to give a tree
decomposition of graphs in MK into
pieces
which themselves are have bounded local
tree width okay and then essentially so
sort of it's they use the decomposition
theorems like with the with the automata
to break it up into be pieces of low
bound local trees and then use this okay
but know this itself doesn't have
bounded local tree with sorry what am I
saying
that's right right so in terms of this
picture yet fits their class of bounded
degree obviously which don't what do I
want to say here
I think excluded minors
excluding minors doesn't generalize this
it generalizes this this is what I'm
trying to say and it certainly doesn't
now is incomparable against that right
okay I think that's right okay
but this the there's sequence of further
results which I'm not going to go on
about the evaluation of first-order
logic this culminated in this paper in
2015 by Roy criterion C bits showing
that first-order logic is fixed
parameter tractable on any nowhere dense
class of graphs and now our dance class
of graphs are a sort of natural limit
these methods all rely on the fact that
these class of graphs are sparse and
exactly what this notion of sparsity is
and what the limit is is I think but
it's very nicely captured in the
definition of nowhere dense classes
which is what I want to get to next to
introduce it I want to first introduce
the idea of a shadow by now
so the graphics a H is a minor of G this
is just the recap of the definition h is
a minor of G if there's a collection of
disconnected disjoint connected sub
graphs of G one for each vertex of H so
whenever there's an edge between two
vertices of H there's an edge between
two vertices in these what I call the
branches it was just an alternative way
of stating the definition I had before
these are the branch sets witnessing the
way it is in G if we can choose the
branch sets in such a way that in each
branch set there's an element so that
the whole branch set is contained within
the our neighborhood of that element we
say that H is a minor at depth R of G
okay so the point is that H is a minor
of G and the branch sets these connected
components are to witness it each of
them is a graph of radius at most R
so another way of saying this is in this
in getting H as a minor G you help you
perform edge deletions and vertex
deletions and contractions but you know
you didn't see these contractions as
contracting or connected subgraph you're
not contracting some graphs of radius
bigger than bigger than are in getting
age okay so each of the minor of G at a
restricted depth and this allows us to
stay sixth inked ly the definition of
nowhere attends classes which is due to
the Arak national and but reason also
another Mendes a transfer graphs is now
where dense if for any fixed value of R
we can find a graph H R which is not a
minor at depth are of any graph in C
right so the Class C may not exclude any
minors in that every graph might appear
as a minor somewhere and C but as you do
it you must increase this radius R okay
if you fix the bound radius R then you
exclude some minor fix the the the depth
of this okay and the idea is it's called
nowhere dense because it has some really
nice properties you can ignore this last
bit of the more
it has really nice properties which show
that these classes are sparse in a sense
okay their heritage fairly sparse in
that you take any sub u you start with
the class and you take sub graphs you
still have a sparse or maybe you take a
class and close it under sub graphs and
it'll still be sparse in this sense and
there are natural limit because of this
absolutely lovely trichotomy theorem
which yarek and portrays proved which
can be stated like this so say you have
an infinite class of graphs I associate
with it the following parameter
let's see our be the collection of
graphs you get as miners of graphs in C
at depth armor okay so those graphs
which you can get this may be richer
than C itself among those graphs in CR
take the number of edges in G it's log
divided by the number of vertices in G
okay so now note this is going to be
somewhere between zero and two because
the number of edges is at most the
square of the number of vertices so this
ratio is going to be somewhere between
zero and two and you take it slim soup
as overall graphs and then you take the
limit of that as R goes to infinity this
is a parameter you associate with a with
the graph Class C right and its value is
somewhere between zero and two well what
they prove is in fact it can take only
this for any Class C this can only take
three possible values 0 1 or 2 and now
we're dens class are exactly those where
it doesn't take value 2 so there the in
a sense the completely characterized as
the classes where you cannot construct a
dense class of graphs by this process of
taking shadow miners ok so I mean this I
think gives some confidence that this is
a natural limiting case of sparse graph
classes what characterizes the 0
well zero is really just a trivial cases
I'm you know the engine is grass right
and so one is really the know where
dense classes though other than the
tribulation this case yeah no no you're
right you're right okay okay so now as I
said this recent result of growing
coaches see births shows that this first
order satisfaction is fixed parameter
tractable on any nowhere dance class
okay and so this generalizes all of
these okay and it's again it's an
Internet application of three things
there's you have guys wants locality
theorem but it needs a certain
adaptation okay rather clever adaptation
so an algorithmic result about sparse
neighborhood covers which I'm not going
to go into because I sort of don't have
time and the fact that these nowhere
dance classes have a certain property
called quasi wideness and this I think
is interesting so I'll say a little bit
more about it okay because this notion
of course you wideness came up in a in a
different context of studying
preservation theorems in finite model
theory so let me explain a little bit
about the the quasi whiteness and then
I'll close with one quick slide in which
I'll say how its put together to get
this fixed parameter tractability was
also what is quasi whiteness
because we mask on the ethnic is up
before we saw them it was linear for the
bounded degree quadratic this is better
I mean so even the excluded minor I
didn't tell you but the flume and grow a
paper actually gave something like n to
the 5 but this improves on that this
basically says that you can get an
algorithm which is n to the 1 plus
epsilon for arbitrary small epsilon so
it's better than quadratic
okay
so what is the white class so let's say
a set of vertices in a graph is are
scattered if they're pairwise distance
is greater than 2 or in other words our
neighbourhoods are disjoint okay so we
see a class of graphs is wide if
whenever you fix our nm there is a bound
so that any graph bigger than that will
contain an are scattered set of size n
ok so in any large enough graph you find
lots of points that are far away far
apart the traffic is out example is
class of graphs a bounded degree and I
think what again the arrogant part ratio
is essentially this is the only class
that you know variations of this are
really all you get as white classes
right but it's clear why the class of
graphs of boundary degree for any fixed
bound is whined right in any large
enough graph I mean once you fix our nm
you can compute about n so that if you
have more than n vertices there must
contain em vertices all pairwise
distance greater than R apart the simple
case of sparse class of sparse graphs
which is not wide is trees because
obviously I can construct
please consider of just depth one
arbitrarily large and everything is
distance too so it's not a wide class
okay
so trees are what we call almost white
so grass of class or graphs is almost
wide if there is a fixed bounds now give
an RM then in any large enough graph in
the class we need to remove at most s
elements to get an are scattered set of
size n right so in a tree in this tree I
can always remove the central element
and I only need to remove one to get a
scattered set right then everything is
sort of distance infinity in this
particular tree and this is true of
arbitrary trees so why is this fix our
nm in any large enough tree either I
have a very long path on that path I can
find a scattered set I can choose points
that are far apart from each other so
there's already scattered set if there
isn't a long path and the tree is very
big there must be a point of high
branching I just removing that one point
will create a large scattered set so I
never need to remove more than one
element to create a large scattered set
that's why we say trees are almost white
okay so trees are almost white now I'll
tell you planar graphs are almost white
and this is not at all obvious requires
work by the state the claim in planar
graphs are wide and the value of s is
three possibly even two
I think - okay I'm trying to think of
the proof I think - works and in fact it
works for any class of graphs of
excluded minors if you exclude the K
clique as a minor then K minus 2 is
sufficient that's what I was saying
three because planar graphs explode five
click as a minor but I think from the K
3 3 you'll get you'll get 2 but ok and
this proof that any class would exclude
the minors is almost white as well its
period various forms but in our paper
with a serious and for non homo horses
and preservation there's I think a good
exposition of this
so this leads us to the third step Kwasi
white classes so here the point was that
s was a fixed parameter we get quasi
white by relaxing this further and
letting s be a function of R okay so now
s is a function and we say class of
graphs is quasi wide with margin s if
for any R M we and any large enough
graph we can find a set of vertices of
size at most s fr so that this removing
them you get an are scattered set of
size at least m and this proof that any
class with excluded minors is almost
wide extends almost directly to showing
that any nowhere dense class is quasi
wide okay so any know our dance class is
quasi void and again this yari compadre
show that this is essentially
characterizes them in the sense that the
nowhere dance class are the only quasi
white class is closed under taking sub
graphs the this is closely related to
nowhere denseness and this is this quasi
whiteness property is what grow at all
use to show that first order logic
evaluation of first order formulas is
FPT on no variance classes and I'll only
give you a very rough exposition in the
two minutes remaining we want to
evaluate a formula from this know a
dense class
we know this graph this class is quasi
wide from this formula Phi we calculate
the radius of neighborhoods we're
interested in this which we get from
graph lines theorem we identify in fact
we may assume that this formula is a
basic local sentence to start with so
the radius is given we identify
bottlenecks set as this is a set of
vertices removing which will create a
Scott Scott large scattered set
in the graph you get by removing these
you color the remaining vertices with
colors indicating how they were
connected to the vertices in s right
you've removed this but you want to
remember how it was connected to the
rest of it you do that by attaching
labels or colors to the remaining
vertices and then you can convert the
formula Phi to one that talks about
these okay now in this graph we have
this large scattered set and it's
neighborhoods are all disjoint and we
want to recursively use this algorithm
to evaluate the pipes to determine the
types of the neighborhoods so what
worked in the case of when I showed you
the proof of bounded local tree which
was that once we've looked at the
neighborhoods we knew that things were
tractable because they had bounded tree
width here we don't have anything like
that all we know is I mean these
neighborhoods themselves belong to this
class C which is nowhere dense and so we
have to recursively carry on this
process the trouble is that because when
you do this you're changing the formula
by putting in these additional colors
this will only work if the depth of
recursion is bounded by a constant right
otherwise the formula length becomes a
function of the size of the graph and
your whole fixed parameter tractability
will break down so you have to make sure
that the formula lens doesn't blow up
too much and this was sort of the main
obstacle to doing this and then okay so
the idea is because you have this large
scatter set you find you're bound to
find certain neighborhoods of the same
type you can remove them from the graph
and you get a smaller graph and you and
you and you carry on the recursion so
now the key element here and I don't
really have time to explain this is to
get this bound they're unable to bound
this recursion by a constant instead
what they do is they prove a refined
version of guys men's theorem where the
quantifier rank doesn't blow up if you
count these let me go back in a basic
local sentence
oh it was far but uh okay a basic local
sentence I'll go of this a basic local
sentence right says there exist points
far apart satisfying a certain fine
the far apart requires a certain amount
of quantifiers to say in a way they say
we shouldn't count those quantifiers and
they prove us what they call a rank
preserving version of Guise Mencia where
you know if you don't count those
quantifiers you don't increase the
quantifier rank of the formula in going
to this guy's my normal form and then
they show that there's a sort of way of
advertising this this point of our rank
during this recursion which they can
bound in the process which you know get
gets gets around this problem that the
depth of recursion is unbounded and the
sparse neighborhood covers I don't even
have chance to define I mean it's a it's
another thing I mean it's a it's a sort
of nice theorem as I said which is a
nice culmination of this line of work on
on sparse graphs but I'm out of time so
I think I'll stop here questions
so in the previous lecture you had
pointed out that for founded tree with
there's a general algorithmic paradigm
based on dynamic programming allows you
to kind of you know
take a first stab at establishing you
know the fixed parameter tractable
algorithm for a particular problem these
extended forms like let's say founded
local tree with excluded minor do we
have a of course it's not going to be as
general where it might fail but do we
have some algorithmic paradigms besides
the first order stuff I mean besides the
first oral sellout what I mean it's not
algorithmic paradigm it says if you
happen to be able to express the
property in a algorithmic paradigms
analogous to the dynamic programming
paradigm that if I see I see yes well I
mean there are some things
particularly you know there that there
are various things on optimization
problems on planar graphs which look
very much like this you know you look at
you know bounded radius neighborhoods
and they provide sort of you're trying
to optimize some function over a planar
graph and but by looking at bounded
bounded size neighborhoods you
essentially only need to look at what
happens on the boundary of these things
and so on and that can be seen as as
manifestations of this but I mean this
is just a loose analogy and I think that
kind of thing extends from planar graphs
to graphs and better-known or any
surface and so on so it's very much
starts to look like these excluded minor
classes and so on
but I mean I'm I'm a bit out of my
comfort zone here no one extends all of
these yes it's a itself at the bottom of
is extending all oh so extruded minors
now attends body local tree with is no
evidence
there are interesting questions so let
me just say a few sorts of things
so these rely on sparsity first-order
logic is as far as the first order
formula is concerned it doesn't matter
whether you say there is an edge or you
say there's not an edge right
I mean so this whole argument works even
if the non edges form a sparse class
right as far as the evaluation of your
sort of form so an interesting question
is well can you characterize the classes
right where where first-order evaluation
will work where this kind of technique
will will work what is the general case
right we in some sense parse it is not a
sufficient explanation oh I mean it's
not a it's not necessary one
what else
there is a sense there's a companion
result which says in some sense this is
a natural limit which says that if you
restrict yourself to class oh graphs
which are closed undertaking sub graphs
right and first order evaluation is FPT
then it must be nowhere dense in a
certain sense okay but the important
character you know caveat there is
closed undertaking sub-graphs so if you
relaxed that what interesting classes
can you get where first order evaluation
is FPT that's a another interesting
question i don't know i mean i don't
know i mean the constants I mean those
functions are horrible and they're
horrible even already bounded tree which
as I said the probably nor non
elementary lower bounds and so on so I
don't know what there is much to be said
there
right right right right right yes yes
yes Kate does that extend to nowhere
dance right I don't know I should here
did you have a question no oh sorry okay
I think we better stop here and